the work i've
done over the last 30 years since i left
the gsb has been very interesting
intersection of business and technology
and creativity
it's only after i left the business
school that i came to enjoy working with
technology and doing cool things with it
when i graduated there was a huge
recession and i kind of decided to go
the entrepreneurial route did one
startup doing control systems our focus
was on doing large concerts we had
clients like the grateful dead actually
so i graduated from stanford and a year
later i was on tour with a grateful dad
living in a tour bus
it really helped me learn how the
product work how the industry worked
learn the customers and it was
incredibly educational for my six weeks
of concert touring being a roadie we
sold that company and then saw a ted
video that i was really inspired by
these professors flying fleets of drones
in formation and i thought wow that'd be
really cool to do an entertainment so i
found
a group of young robotics engineers and
we joined forces
we spent three years developing the
technology and then have been flying
shows for the last two years
we make drones and the software needed
to have them all performed in a
coordinated manner to do all kinds of
interesting things in the sky
drones can make almost anything in the
sky they are 3d repositionable pixels
and so we are
developing an entire system both
hardware and software that makes it easy
to deploy these drones and have them do
what our clients want them to do
the entrepreneurial courses at stanford
gave me a really solid grounding in
terms of how to think about business
opportunities what's needed to get in
place in order to be successful how to
think long term how to think
strategically many of these lessons hold
true today and are really important as
you're figuring out how to grow a
business into something really
successful and lasting
where things have shifted for me lately
is normally i was behind the scenes and
because we are exploring new territory
with drones and pushing the envelope
we've been much more the creatives
ourselves that's why we just went on
america's got talent and it was a really
kind of crazy situation because i never
really
envisioned myself being on stage but
there i was and
we put on this really awesome
performance and it was different and
unusual to actually sort of be in front
of the camera and be the talent and to
be showcasing the work that we've been
working so hard on over the last five
years
[Applause]
so one of the things that they always
talked about at stanford during the
entrepreneurship classes is that there
is no single path and that entrepreneurs
come from all walks of life and there
are opportunities everywhere and
i think i have lived that 100 percent my
name is nils thorgesson i'm the ceo of
verge era
you